One of the funny things about owning a brain...
...is that you have no control over the things that it gathers and holds on to,...
...the facts and the stories.
And as you get older, it only gets worse.
Things stick around for years sometimes before you understand why you're interested in them,...
...before you understand their import to you.
Here's three of mine.
When Richard Feynman was a young boy in Queens,...
...he went for a walk with his dad and his wagon and a ball.
And he noticed that when he pulled the wagon, the ball went to the back of the wagon.
And he asked his dad, "Why does the ball go to the back of the wagon?"
And his dad said, "That's inertia."
He said, "What's inertia?"